Hello, my beautiful children, get ready to put
on your stilettos and burn some sage, bitches,
because it's episode 6 of
"American Horror Story: Apocalypse",
and this one's a real tearjerker.
After I died of laughter for the
first two minutes of this episode,
Mr. and Mrs. James - aka Madison and
Behold - sign the deed to Murder House.
Madison has been instructed by
Cordelia to search Langdon's childhood home
for clues about Michael's past.
If they're gonna show Michael
as pure evil, they'll need proof.
The real estate agent tells them
he's legally obligated to tell them
about the deaths that have
happened on the property - all 36 of them.
But seeing as Behold and Madison are badass
magic users, they decide to purchase it, anyway,
even though Madison
refers to it as a shithole.
Then again, she's always a diva and
Behold isn't afraid to call her out on it.
Behold tries to use magic on
the front door, but it doesn't work.
The powers of the witches and
warlocks here are thrown off kilter,
Behold telling Madison that the psychic
energy here is stronger than he's ever felt before.
It's not a home but a prison,
a prison for the murdered victims,
Behold even saying, "I pity the
souls trapped here. It must be Hell."
And if you've seen season 1, we know that for the
ghosts that roam Murder House, it is their own Hell.
They're trapped there for good.
Later on, when the satanists arrive, we'll learn
that the house itself was built on a portal to Hell.
Behold takes out his warlock
supplies to prepare for a ritual.
Michael's family died in this home
and they need those spirits to show
themselves, so they can find out more about him.
He reads from a spell book, saying,
"Monstra te spirituum, ne abscondas"
which is Latin for "Show
your spirits, do not hide".
We get a brief glimpse of one of the
nurses who died in Murder House season 1,
the smoldering children
and, back by popular demand,
it's Tate, who's in the middle of
ghost therapy with Dr. Ben Harmon.
Tate is dealing with
normal ghosts problems.
He's being ignored by the love of his life, Violet -
or love of his death, if we want to get literal -,
because she found out he shot up a
school and impregnated her mother.
Jeez, Violet, he's a
changed man, get over it.
Madison and Behold
interrupt the session.
They seem to know
all about Ben and Tate.
Behold even brings up that Ben's wife,
Vivien, died giving birth to Michael.
He's the child of a human,
Vivien, and spirit, Tate.
If you remember from season 1,
Billie Dean Howard, medium to the stars,
predicted the very
nature of the Antichrist.
"A child born of human and spirit
will usher in the end of times."
"It is the essence of evil."
Tate warns them that even people
protected from magic aren't safe in this house.
But Madison and Behold aren't
going to leave empty-handed.
They promise to get out of the spirits' hair
as long as they answer some questions.
But the house has a
few tricks up its sleeve.
As a creepy red ball drops from the
stairs, Madison is tackled by Beau,
Constance Langdon's handsome
son she kept locked in the attic.
He's shooed off Madison by
none other than Billie Dean,
who we learn is alive, being allowed to walk freely
in and out of the house, unharmed by the spirits.
And then we get one of the most epic moments so far this season: the return of Constance Langdon, who says,
"And this is my fucking house."
Madison and Behold make their intentions known to Constance, who doesn't seem too pleased they're there.
They're interrupted by Moira O'Hara,
yet another character from season 1,
who had sex with Constance's
husband and was subsequently killed for it.
And judging by Constance's back and
forth with her, she's' still not over it.
Madison and Behold question
Constance and Billie about Michael.
She doesn't give away info for free.
If they can abracadabra that
bitch Moira out of the house,
Constance will tell them
everything they need to know.
So they do the only logical thing
and dig up her body in the backyard.
They uncover a
skull, but it's not Moira's.
That was likely the
skull of Hayden McClaine,
the lover of Ben Harmon who was
also buried there back in season 1.
They uncover her bones in what
has to be the weirdest gift ever,
burying her back with her mother,
who she killed back in season 1.
Notice the date of death, 2011,
the year Murder House takes place.
Moira's given a wonderful send-off with her mother,
so she can be smothered with kisses for eternity.
Madison and Behold, victorious
in getting Moira out of the house,
meet with Constance in the hope
she keeps up her end of the bargain.
Constance tells them
everything she knows,
how she assumed the burden of taking care
of Michael after his mother died during birth.
Michael was to be her second chance of raising a
good boy after everything that happened with Tate.
She kept baby Michael in the mirror room,
the same room she used to punish her
daughter Addie when she was being naughty.
As he grew up, he would kill small rodents
and leave them as presents for his mother.
And these gifts just keep getting better.
She realizes that God put her on earth to raise
these monsters, and it gave her a sense of purpose.
After Michael would kill, she would
plant a small rosebush as a burial spot,
until her entire backyard
was filled with bushes.
His first human kill
happened at the age of 3:
His babysitter, who Constance
was able to pass off as a suicide.
But even stranger was the fact
he aged over a decade in one night,
as if he was in a hurry
to get somewhere age-wise.
He then attempts to kill grandma,
almost as if something has taken over him.
He snaps out of it and the two share a
heartwarming grandmother-grandson moment.
With him aging and his sporadic bouts of
choking, she would need secret intervention.
And we all know
how that turned out.
Constance tells them that Michael
made her feel like her life mattered,
but that slowly died away, knowing
at any moment, he could slit her throat.
She was nothing but an invisible
stepping stone to where he was going.
Distraught and feeling betrayed by God, she
ventures into the Murder House and commits suicide,
OD-ing on pills and alcohol.
She never wanted
to see Michael again.
Upon her awakening, she finds
three of her children waiting for her,
Addie noticeably absent, because
if you remember from season 1,
she did not die in the house, rather was
brutally run over by a car on Halloween.
After she tells her story, she's interrupted by
her daughter, who inexplicably has no eyes,
before fading away.
And thank God there was a
commercial break after this scene,
because we then see Ben Harmon tear-jerking it
in what has to be the saddest happy ending ever.
Madison and Behold promise him if he
tells them what he knows about Michael,
they can fix his,
ahem, crying problems.
Michael uncovers his grandmother's body and Ben
tells him his grandmother doesn't want to see him.
The spirits in this house can only
be seen when they want to be seen.
Ben wants to help him.
He can't help but think of him as his
own son, even though biologically, he isn't.
In a sweet little montage, they do fun things like
play catch and make crosses on Rubik's cubes,
when Michael meets his real dad.
"Stay away from my
shit, you understand?"
It's heartwarming,
to say the least.
Papa Tate makes Tatertot cry, saying not even himself could make something as monstrous as Michael.
Michael turns away from good and embraces the dark side, performing gruesome surgeries in the basement.
When the house sells, he kills the
new owners, showing no remorse.
But even more stunning is his
ability to destroy their souls.
In a display of his new power, one
he doesn't realize he has himself,
he lights the two souls on fire,
making them cease to exist.
Ben then turns on him, telling him
he could have never helped Michael.
And now Michael has lost the only
two figures who have loved him in life.
This betrayal by the ones who loved him most
is likely the catalyst for him going full evil.
Madison says they need to go back to
Cordelia and tell her what they know.
Their new Supreme is pure evil.
But they're interrupted by Vivien,
Michael's biological mother,
and Ben goes to take
care of the crying baby.
If you remember from season 1,
Vivien gives birth to two children,
one of whom died during the
birth, the other being Michael.
She warns Madison and Behold, quoting
a passage from Revelations Chapter 13,
referring to the Antichrist:
Then I saw a beast with ten horns
and seven heads rising out of the sea
and all who dwell on
the earth will worship Him.
Vivian describes her
experience with Michael,
how crows would circle the house, how hot
it was inside in the arrival of the Black Pope,
Anton LaVey and his cardinals,
one of them being Mead, the other
played by the actress who played Pepper.
Anton tells him it's time to
remove the scales from his eyes.
In the Book of Revelations, there are
a number of references to a dragon.
Vivien tells them at first, she
didn't take the satanists seriously.
They were lost souls following a conman
from some circus, a nod to "Freak Show".
Everything seemed
fine until the Black Mass.
Mead pulls up and offers a ride to a young girl
as "Dont Fear the Reaper" plays on the radio.
The girl says, "Thanks, you're a lifesaver",
but we know her life will be far from safe.
Notice the upside-down cross
hanging from the rear view mirror
and the syringe
Mead stabs the girl with.
It's such a lovely
night for murder, isn't it?
The Black Mass begins with Anton copping a
feel and passing a dagger to one of the cardinals.
She tells Michael,  "It's all for you".
"It's all for you."
A nod to 1976's "The Omen".
In a scene from "Temple of Doom", Anton pulls out
the young girl's heart and it's given to Michael to eat.
Yum.
And we watch as the shadow
of the devil looms over him,
the other satanists
bowing in reverence.
Vivien, fearing what Michael has
become, makes the decision to kill him.
As she does, she notices 666,
the number of the Beast that was described in the Bible passage Vivien mentioned earlier from Revelations.
Her attempt to kill Michael fails as he engulfs
her in flames, only for her to be saved by Tate.
From that day forward, he was gone.
Vivien says neither Ben nor Tate were the
father, rather he was born from the evil of the house.
The source of darkness is his true father
and he has come to destroy the world,
bringing Billie Jean's
prophecy to fruition.
Madison and Behold prepare to leave,
Behold telling her that if he had known Michael was
this evil, they would never have made him Supreme.
He asks her what they
would do if they can't stop him,
a question Madison
doesn't have the answer to.
Violet explains to
Madison her troubles with Tate,
and in a real turn for Madison's
character, she consoles her,
telling her that the real evil
isn't Tate, rather the house.
It used him as a vessel
to commit those evil deeds.
She thinks that the evil
inside Tate left with Michael,
giving Violet hope of a future
relationship with her sexy ghost boy.
Madison blows some fairy
dust so she can look fabulous
and she now magically
knows how Tate saved her mom.
They embrace as The Police "Spirits of
the Material World" plays in the background,
Madison and Behold
driving back to Cordelia.
This episode focused
primarily on backstory.
In fact, it really didn't
advance the plot at all.
But I was okay with that, since we learned more
about who Michael is and how he became that way.
His upbringing was one of tragedy,
his mother dying in childbirth and the two people
who cared for him the most turning their backs on him.
It's no wonder when the satanists
arrived telling him he was special,
that he turned to them
and embraced his true path.
But this episode was a total
nostalgia trip for fans of season 1,
getting to reunite
with old characters,
giving a proper send-off
to Moira and Constance,
and finally answering
what made Tate so evil.
What I'm interested in is how the witches will use this new information to gain the upper hand on Michael.
Who will they need to seek out in
order to put a stop to Michael for good?
We know it won't go over well because
the apocalypse does eventually happen,
but with the witches thankfully surviving,
I think the key to all this resides with Mallory.
In the last episode,
we saw her heal a deer.
But not only did she he heal it, it
regained its youth, becoming a doe.
If Michael can banish souls for
good, can Mallory bring them back?
Is she the key to somehow
reverting the apocalypse?
And what will Ariel do when he
finds out about Michael's true past?
Remember, Mead told Michael not
to bring up who his father was to him
and Ariel only wanted Michael to be
Alpha so he could stick it to the witches.
Not to mention, we still don't know
what's gonna happen in the current timeline.
Cordelia raised Coco, Dinah and Mallory from
the dead before they were interrupted by Michael.
What will he do to them - or
rather, what will they do to him?
That's it for this breakdown.
If you liked this video,
make sure to give it a like,
and if you didn't, meet me
out back by the gazebo.
I also have a new Twitter, where you can get updates
on my latest videos, or if you just want to troll me.
And last but not least because I was
a bad boy and didn't do it last week
I want you all to remember,
Daddy loves you very much.